Elijah has changed over the years he's
given up we keep him heavily sedated but
there is a reason for that
he's too smart for them you won't be
lonely anymore we have two new friends
[Music]
the three of you think you have
extraordinary gifts like something out
of a comic book I've developed an
effective treatment for this disorder
the light will force a different
identity to take off step away from the
controls now so you're not gonna shake
my hand and let me walk out of here
good for you what do you want I am here
to see if tales of the extraordinary be
are true may I meet the Beast
I need your abilities to get us all out
of here and show the world we exist that
sounds like the bad guys is teaming up
then you believe you are an avenging
angel
I've been just
I have to get out of here before he gets
out they are contained
they always underestimate the master
line
it has become David I found someone will
require your full potential
you shouldn't be hiding in the shadows
you might want to try and stop us
a lot of people are going to die
now look like a PB&J sandwich finally
all of us together for the world to see
what we are capable of you need to get
out of there
what have you done all night
you